hello this is presh talwalkar
i am the author of multiply numbers by
drawing lines
please check out my book it's the first
text that's been written about this
visual way to multiply numbers
in this video i'm going to teach you a
trick i discovered while writing the
book which is a rotation trick from the
diagram
first let's review how you multiply
numbers by drawing lines
let's say you want to multiply 12 by 13.
for the one in twelve we'll draw one
line
for the two
we'll leave a little bit of space and
draw two lines
for the other number
we'll draw lines in the other direction
now we will group up intersections of
the lines
on the far right there are six
intersections
in the middle there are five
intersections
and on the left there's one intersection
these numbers tell you what the answer
is so 12 times 13 is 156
but there's a cool thing you can do now
that you've drawn the diagram
let's remove some of the labels
now what we're going to do is rotate
this entire diagram 90 degrees
and the thing i discovered
is that you now get a new diagram and
this can solve a new multiplication
problem
let's look at the lines that are going
to the upper right
here we have one line
and then we have three lines
so that means the first number we're
multiplying is thirteen
for the lines in the other direction
we have two lines followed by one line
which represents the number twenty-one
so this diagram represents 13 times 21.
we can again group the intersections
that are vertically aligned
we have three on the right
seven in the center and two on the left
and that gives us our answer that 13
times 21 is
273
and this is really cool we've solved
another problem from the same diagram
we've already drawn
but we can even do more
let's go ahead and rotate this diagram
by 90 degrees once more
we now have a new diagram
and we can solve another multiplication
problem
the lines going up and to the right are
two lines followed by one line which is
21.
the lines going to the bottom right
are three lines
and then one line
so that's 31
so this diagram represents 21 times 31.
we'll now count up vertically aligned
intersections
there's one on the right
five in the center
and six on the left
so that means 21 times 31 is 651
we're not done yet we can do this one
more time
we'll rotate the diagram 90 degrees
now there's a pattern each time you
rotate the diagram
it turns out that you're going to switch
the two numbers and switch the digits in
the second number
but let's go ahead and count the lines
anyway
the lines sloping up and to the right
are three lines followed by one line for
31.
the lines sloping down and to the right
are one followed by 2 which is 12.
we now count up the intersections
there's 2 on the right
7 in the center
and 3 on the left
so we have 31 times 12 is 372.
if we rotate one more time we're back to
our original problem of 12 by 13.
now with this one diagram can solve four
different problem problems depending on
how you orient it
so it's really amazing that there's a
hidden geometry to arithmetic
and even though millions have of people
have seen videos about multiplying
numbers by drawing lines
this is the first time that a video has
been made to show you how you can rotate
the diagram and solve other problems
so this connects geometry and arithmetic
in a completely unsurprising way
so it's a cool trick i hope you like it
and please share this video
if you enjoyed this concept please check
out my book multiply numbers by drawing
lines
thanks for watching
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math and game theory
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions
you can follow mind your decisions on
facebook google plus and patreon
you can also catch me at preshtalwalker
on twitter instagram tumblr and
pinterest
and you can get all of my books there's
a link in the video description